[Musik]
wie geht es mit deutsch allianz die
bringen indem wir genau da wo austragen
mich schon der putzfrau und verschiedene
hochschulprofessor ist das auch mit
handschuhen
da hat ganz normal
[Musik]
wir müssen nachweisen dass ihnen ein
gefahr droht glauben uns das nur wenn
wir das auf dem papier nachweisen können
wissen sie allenfalls ob sie in welchem
monat sie geboren sind
[Musik]
zur hauptstraße hatten in afghanistan
dieser betrag sollte die länge der
chance wurde also ich finde ich dass
irgendetwas falsch
[Musik]
hier könnte das auch ob ihr müsst euch
nur den aufschlüssen und und flüchtlinge
besser hätte das board mitglieder meines
quo trifft
[Musik]
genau
bringen
das letzte vor ein paar wochen erst sind
sie angekommen fremde sprache fremde
kultur des interviews oft gar nicht von
mir
es kommt mir vor wie ein trainer ist
aber der sozial vorstand von neftenbach
und damit auch verantwortlich für
asylbewerber über ihre asylgesuche aber
entscheidet der bund und das dauert noch
vier monat würste wo sie stand aber es
wird so nicht sie machen mit der welt
versorgt mit dem fc kabul
ersten sieg bald okay
es ruft 62 er war fluglotse und
eigentlich ist er pensioniert
wie die jungfrau zum kind sei er zu
dieser aufgabe bekommen
vor zwei jahren wurde er für die fdp in
den gemeinderat gewählt
dann staub
seinen stärken organisieren und
motivieren
so schafft er es dass seine schützlinge
ihre fußballschuhe gesponsert bekommen
der asylchef ist unkompliziert wir sind
schnell bei uns redlichkeit gebiet vom
sozial vorstand ist nur vernünftig dass
rücker vielfältig hat sein dass nicht
ganz auf dem fahrzeug gewartet hast du
sagen gesucht überhaupt nicht richtig
bei dir wohl länger dabei sind die hand
ware und verletzt ist denn heut'
sozialamt übrig bleibe für mich aber der
zwischenzeit hat 60 akkumulierte
spannende lüthi hat er keine
die spannenden leute bereiten ihm aber
auch sorgen
sie kosten viel fürsorge geld zehn jahre
lang bezahlen der bund und der kanton
für die flüchtlinge die schulkosten aber
müssen neftenbach zum größten teil
selber finanzieren
das kostet kraft und raucher mindestens
das schmeckt einfach praktisch und für
konkret wegen der flüchtlingskinder sind
die steuern um zwei prozent gestiegen
die steuerzahler kostet das im schnitt
rund 70 franken mehr pro jahr
[Musik]
das baby pause wie trier seit einem
halben jahr ist sie hier
und macht kaum fortschritte trotz 13
stunden deutschunterricht pro woche und
der anders reha ein aufgewecktes 13
jähriges mädchen darin partie mit ihrem
bruder ist sie seit drei monaten hier
ihre eltern stammen aus afghanistan
aufgewachsen aber ist sie in der türkei
[Musik]
neue heimat neftenbach 5500 einwohner 55
davon asylbewerber und anerkannte
flüchtlinge also ein prozent der
bevölkerung
die meisten leben in häusern die das
sozialamt gemietet hat
[Musik]
jans vater das asylgesuch der familie
ist offen
der bund entscheidet ob sie in der
schweiz bleiben darf schaeffler erhält
keine informationen zu ihrem fall
ich frage mich sind sie politisch
verfolgt oder sind es
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge hans eltern sagen
aus afghanistan seien sie zuerst in den
iran geflohen dann in die türkei
ich meine ich muss wirklich mehr
unterbringen und nachher wird
integration soll opera aus anderen also
keine zeit mich zu sagt wohl da ist was
nachher dem politischen flüchtlingen
oder ist das ein wirtschaftsflüchtling
es glaubt ihr grant ich bin wahnsinnig
froh dass ich diejenige usc wolfgang das
ist unmöglich
re hans mutter eine analphabetin
sie sagt aus angst vor den taliban habe
sie das haus nicht verlassen dürfen ihre
tochter solle freie liegen
gleichzeitig aber will die mutter an dem
festhalten was für sie eine tradition
ist für mich bist keine folge das was
man ihr gesagt
nächstes jahr wenn sie 14 jahre alt ist
soll hahn das kopftuchtragen hans eltern
sie sind cousins ihre heirat wurde
arrangiert als sie 18 waren beide aber
sagen sie hätten sich von anfang an
geliebt
[Musik]
in unserer kultur ist das nicht erlaubt
das ist uns völlig fremd
integration heißt natürlich nicht dass
man nachher 0 und afghanen bleibt das
muss auch in beruf und so muss man keine
tanten alle zusammen schaffen und
dadurch konnte das passieren
aufprall der kulturen
[Musik]
was wissen sie über flüchtling von acht
oder gar natürlich 10.000
wehrpflichtigen sind am 3
[Musik]
denken sie nur an
schließlich ist holland aus mit der
hamas ist kühl haben sich so kann man
verlieren jetzt gut danke schön wenn es
mit einem kriminalität vor dem handel
und aus ihrer stadt
[Musik]
jetzt möchte dass du mir zeigst wenn sie
sich dafür interessiert wenn sie das
jetzt gerade gerne hat dass man es
eigentlich verstecken
weit weg von der heimat ist sam hacker
sei sogar ihr kind fremd in eritrea
sagte übersetzer hätte das ganze dorf
bei der erziehung geholfen in neftenbach
macht das jetzt eine hebamme im auftrag
von ich wusste nicht dass ich mit dem
kind sprechen muss ich wusste nur dass
eine mutter ihr baby füttert und es
wäscht ich dachte ich spreche erst mit
dem kind wenn es zweijährig ist die idee
früh in mutter und kind investieren um
später kosten zu sparen etwa für
nachhilfe in der schule
die früherziehung koste jährlich 6000
franken rechnet der sozial vorstand mehr
vor
neftenbach teile sich die kosten mit dem
kanton aber die eritreerin verschiebe
viele termine oder sagte sie ganz ab das
sind schwierige situation als ganzes
programm wo man eigentlich weitermachen
für die integration von denen liegt und
das geht natürlich nur wenn sie da ist
dazu gehöre auch ein deutschkurs und
wegen ihres babys hat sich die
anerkannte flüchtlingsfrau bisher
geweigert deutsch zu lernen
dabei lebt sie seit bald zwei jahren in
der schweiz auf kosten der fürsorge
renitenten könne er höchstens dass
fürsorge geld kürzen
du hast dich hier ausstellen ihnen
folgten ducroz wasche ich noch teilen
kreieren und auf zusammen
wenn du mal kommt das flüchtlinge besser
steuern runter statt das ist mir
mitteilte dass ich zum teil
darum werde er ein anreizsystem
einführen
rund 20 prozent weniger fürsorge geld
für alle flüchtlinge den vollen betrag
bekämen nur wer die
integrationsprogramme besucht er bietet
an selber ins tessin zu transferieren
sie lehnt ab ihre tante habe selber drei
kinder und könne ihr nicht helfen
sie wolle lieber in neftenbach bleiben
dann möchten wir dich doch die augen
werden
in einem intensivkurs mit betreuung für
jahre
da muss doch wirklich regelmäßig dann in
die schule gehen also man kann da nicht
eine woche zur tante gehen ins tessin
es ist wirklich heftig dass man hier ist
ob das wohl gelingt oder es selber eine
schweizerin die sich der integration
verweigert
so einfach ist die sache nicht semmer
ist unfreiwillig alleinerziehend ihr
freund filmen der vater ihrer tochter
ist kurz nachdem h in die schweiz
gekommen
auf sein asylgesuch aber trat der bund
gar nicht erst ein
und das obwohl beide durch italien
reißen ohne von den italienischen
behörden registriert worden zu sein
und bischof frau und dann ist sie
zuständig und beim film oder software
bug sie das ist aber überhaupt nicht
geantwortet
sie hatten recht fahrzeugen führt
antwort sie hat nicht geantwortet und
die dann fall ist nach italien zuständig
alle das heißt nicht bewiesen
ausschlaggebend sondern auch ein
drittstaat wie er italiens geantwortet
oder die antwort bestand
das ist richtig also so hat nichts
weiter völlig absurd
also mal erlebt
die schweiz schaffte filmon nach italien
aus dreimal schon weil er immer wieder
zu seiner familie zurückkehrt jetzt ist
er wieder in haft
[Musik]
hinter dieser praxis steht das
dublin-abkommen es kann familien
auseinander reißen
ich lebe in angst ich will mit meinem
freund zusammen sein aber die polizei
schafft ihn immer wieder aus die
gemeinsame tochter ccm als freund seit
einem jahr nur noch so viel man isst
kein verbrecher aber weil er mehrmals
gegen das einreiseverbot verstoßen hat
sitzt er nun fast 17 monate lang im
gefängnis nur abgeschreckt werde dadurch
nicht schliesslich habe die schweiz
seine freundin als flüchtling anerkannt
er wolle bei seiner familie leben was
soll man italien
dort gibt es nichts es gibt keine
sozialhilfe wir müssten auf der straße
leben filmens lange haft fast 100000
franken für die steuerzahler
[Musik]
was ich höre was das keinesfalls dass es
für merkel
also möchte eigentlich zu einer flucht
auf der hofstelle dollar zusätzlicher
zeigte sich zu wiederholen ist also
absolut ist anders machen
[Musik]
kürzt kürzt kürzt und dann hört man die
andere geschichte so ein flüchtiger
kutsche wird wo psychologisch betreut
werden darf mitmachen
da kommen schon mal noch nicht
vorgezeichnet
hier dürfe bisher teil bleibe zum luxus
aus der studie zusammen
da war es mit dabei sind haben wir platz
haben mir trotz ganze zu jung sagt sich
40 kinder zusammen
ja es ist einfach völlig kosten das
thema schönheit und sie dann armen ist
nach schweizer fremd und das ja nicht
und dann sind wir nicht nur dunkelhäutig
wir sind habe ich wie vor liegt das was
man kennt das ist gut und das geht jedem
ort wurde andreas nicht damit dass man
die rückseite
regula neff ist eine der wenigen echten
macherinnen die hilft die flüchtlinge zu
betreuen ehrenamtlich versteht sich im
team von urs näpflin derbe mündlich
schwarz gehört warum machst du das
sozial und unten und pilze frauen dass
diverse fantasievolle lustig wäre dahin
punkten können sie sich bei just bei
unsere internetseite mit den berufen
einloggen blickte die ist noch offen
die heilpädagogin hilft dem 17-jährigen
diamant eine lehrstelle zu finden
diamant stammt aus syrien seit drei
jahren lebt er mit seiner familie hier
als anerkannter flüchtling eine kleine
auswahl wenn sie nicht machen und die
real soll wird größer wenn sie ins
stottern
vermutlich verstärkt durch den krieg und
die flucht die krankenkasse bezahlt eine
traumatherapie der brust noch das in
einem sehr schwierigen jahr in die
schweiz gekommen
so fällt es sie noch matter geometrie
und natürlich sein stottern ist auch ein
problem
[Musik]
er hat auch die drei bord und
bewerbungen nicht geschieden
ganz ehrlich gesagt das ist äußerst
[Musik]
charmant aber sieht seine zukunft ganz
anders die ammanns situation werde durch
seinen vater erschwert
der schneider konnte in den letzten drei
jahren nur ein paar monate auf abruf
arbeiten dass er nicht für seine familie
sorgen keine verletze seine ehre
die vermutung liegt nahe dass aus diesem
grund sie stark und ihre religion
klammert was auch für die kinder nicht
nur einfach ist weil sie sind am samstag
und am sonntag sind sie da fast den
ganzen tag in der kirche
und eben das keine fall zumutungen
aufkommen sind nicht moslems es sind
christen
er zwinge seine söhne nicht in die
kirche zu gehen sagt der vater
über religion aber äußere er sich nicht
privatsache kritikern sage ich hätten
sie den krieg in syrien erlebt hätten
sie mehr verständnis für unsere lage
ich bin nicht faul und will nicht von
der sozialhilfe leben aber die umstände
sind momentan sehr schwierig für uns
[Musik]
und jetzt feierabend
nein noch lange nicht sagt der asylchef
ja
die jungs sollen nicht nur herum hängen
als asylbewerber dürfen sie die vom
kanton bezahlten deutschkurse nicht
besuchen
vermesser dem moment ist einer irak ich
bin arm sidney ems achse bis 9 grad ab
aber ich glaube das ist unhöflich
nämlich moment auskommen
der lokale fußballverband hat sich
bereit erklärt die afghanen zu
trainieren
der check ist eine soziologisch das
hatte letzten rannte darunter otto mal
probiert außerdem helfe auch wenn sie
die schweiz wieder verlassen müssen
der sozialvorsteher investiert ungefähr
1500 franken pro jahr für ihre
mitgliedschaften im fußballclub
[Applaus]
ich sage mir einfach machen es die leute
nicht zentriert und beste machen so
schnell wie möglich integrieren wo ich
weiß dass die irgendwie arbeitsprozessen
kommen und aber wenn dort erst ob es
einer schafft dann aber eben auch eins
dass die schweiz damit wie sie wisse
dass man jetzt ich bin nachts auch
sofort die integration auf außer ich
glaub nicht dass das 1000 genom spricht
mit bewahren das war es noch so müssen
von bewerbern bescheid das wasser aber
es ist eben so
[Musik]
einen monat später
du weißt du seinen bauernhof ist
du weißt nicht was die tiere halten
der alltag der afghanischen familie
komani zeigt dass die integration so
ihre tücken hat
[Musik]
und das liegt sowohl an den flüchtlingen
als auch an den schweizer
dre hans vater will unbedingt arbeiten
wo so viel bringt ihn zum bauernhof des
gemeindepräsidenten
er bietet einen schnuppertag an
[Musik]
du hast keine gummistiefel dabei das
sind gummistiefel oder welche schuhgröße
hast du ja was sollte ich haben ja dann
gebe ich dir gleich bei ergonomie sagt
im iran habe er felder bewirtschaftet
daneben ist weg darum möchte er als
bauer arbeiten zurück kommt es
automatisch gar das zu weit
[Musik]
die 13-jährige reha sagt sie schien ihre
sich in ihrem bade kleid fühle sie sich
nackt
[Musik]
nein
in der türkei hätten sie keinen
schwimmunterricht gehabt außerdem würden
mädchen dort getrennt von den jungs
schwimmen
[Musik]
hans mutter sagt es habe sie viel
überwindung gekostet hierher zu kommen
ich glaube fast nicht dass ich hier bin
ich habe so etwas noch nie gesehen es
ist schwer zu fassen
die große freiheit in der schweiz macht
mir sorgen die freizügigkeit
es macht man mehr zu sehen dass die
jungs meiner tochter nahe kommen das
muss ich ehrlich sagen
[Musik]
re hans vater er will arbeiten aber ihn
fest anzustellen ist illegal
für asylbewerber gilt in den ersten
monaten ein arbeitsverbot
wichtig ist dass arbeitstraining und
deutschkurse für asylbewerber sobald sie
in der schweiz sind das wurden die sp
und die grünen
[Musik]
wie kommt es dass in neftenbach 90
prozent der asylbewerber und flüchtlinge
von der fürsorge leben das ist schweizer
durchschnitt obwohl sich besonders viel
mühe gibt er verweist auf die bürokratie
für einen kurzen arbeitseinsatz fülle
seine sekretärin stundenlang papiere aus
sicher ärgert mich verrückt aber was man
so eine bürokratie niveau busbetrieb
dass der auf dem ruhigen zugspitze und
kanton oder ein bunter bereich sich alle
beteiligen
für sie galt sowie das ist es so dass du
eigentlich nach west durch die ganzen
verfahren oder die ganze bürokratische
sache machen aber bewusst dass man so
überhaupt nehmen zum schlafen
gelegenheit mit unternehmen das um
soziales meister
das wissen aber auch dass er gegen das
schock die will wird war ich die formula
sind ja so kosslick im krieg geschrieben
dass man das ist weil man sozial
sekretärin vier stunden hat dann habe
ich 12
das problem ist erkannt der bund will
die verfahren vereinfachen
und wie sieht es auf seite der
flüchtlinge aus wenn re hans mutter sagt
sie schwimmen nicht aber sie erlaube es
ihren kindern so ist das nur die halbe
wahrheit
man darf nur noch ein jahr lang
schwimmen bis sie 14 ist dann wird es
die mutter verbieten
die aufgabe von jungen frauen ist es im
haushalt mitzuhelfen und die aufgabe der
jungs zu spielen
das ist keine diskriminierung mädchen
haben andere eigenschaften als jungs er
darlegt sowie die natur ist vorgesehen
hat
[Musik]
jans vater wäre froh er könnte in der
schweizer arbeitswelt fuss fassen
weniger begeistert ist sein potenzieller
chef an seinen polnischen mitarbeiter
habe er sich gewöhnt sagt mehr martin
huber aber jetzt die ganze
integrationsgeschichte von vorn mit
flüchtlingen lieber nicht
motivierte mitarbeiter darüber und deren
dem hintergrund hat ja nur ganze familie
wo alle der mutter wird nämlich der
weiteren sowie rektoren stelle hat und
die bilder wirklich skripten sich wohl
sicher jetzt 1000 gemacht und sie sagen
er hat es gut gemacht
er macht nie der kabarettist staaten und
draufgabe sicheren händler oder wenn man
früher noch zu klagen oder kabul das ist
handels hochburg sich oder bis dann ist
das ein kreiert hat also der politischen
repression model ist er die unternehmer
selbst aber die höhere hand tun der name
oder privatwirtschaft noch nicht
überwunden
klar ich muss ich muss ich muss mir da
völlig okay und sagen es ist
[Musik]
das große du wieviel platz besitzt nur
knapp
also bald wird der freund der eritreerin
selber kasai aus dem gefängnis entlassen
sam hat noch ganz andere sorgen
ihr kind hat nach acht monaten immer
noch keinen geburtsschein das heißt ja
nicht existiert in der schweiz gar nicht
und das liegt am schweizer
zivilgesetzbuch bevor man hier einen
geburtsschein ausstellt will die schweiz
im haus personalien geklärt haben zb ob
sie ledig oder verheiratet ist bei jedem
termin mit dabei ein eritreischer
übersetzer 10h sagt sie sei verheiratet
zwangsverheiratet allerdings durch ihre
eltern in eritrea diesen mann habe sie
aber vor jahren schon verlassen vor
ihrer flucht in die schweiz werden kann
also ist jetzt entscheidend war die
heirat vor sich vor 18 oder noch 18
wenn sie nach auf 10 ist dann kann ich
oder muss ich diese akzeptieren in der
schweiz dann werden sie als
verheiratetes im register eingetragen
und dann gilt eigentlich dieser ehemann
als vater des kindes das er nicht dazu
sagen kann
die preisfrage lautet wie alt war seien
habe der zwangsheirat wissen sie
allenfalls ob sie in welchem monat sie
geboren sind
ich weiß es wird gemäß dem protokoll ist
ist ihr geburtsdatum der erste 92 das
berührungslos ist bei allen dass er es
nicht gewusst wie geburtsdaten überhaupt
kein thema aber leider funktioniert
ich denke ich war unter 18 jährigen
ich denke ich bin einfach verpflichtet
die wahrheit zu beurkunden und deshalb
muss ich so lange vorhaben für nicht
juristische personen sind die abläufe
doch zu verstehen sich der hose gefunden
ich könnte es doch mal auf die idee
stößt machen
nein ist er nicht sie haben hier das
letzte mal gesagt dass sie gehen wie ein
dokument von heirat bekommen haben
es gab ein dokument oder sie können mir
im moment kein offizielles dokument
geben dann versuchen wir mal diesen weg
nochmals ähnlich wie semmer ergeht es
schätzungsweise 3000 flüchtlingsfrauen
mit babys
[Applaus]
nach der verfehlung dome
[Musik]
und was wohl ist das gesprächsthema bei
mir danach übernahmen die 24 langen
schaffen schätzt ob im zug mit dem mit
dem sinn des sports darum echte frau
verordneten etc
frage positioniert
[Musik]
und jetzt haben probiert sie lässig zu
machen und sich zeit der kantons und
dritter manschette definitiven danke und
nike die frau ist verheiratet und jetzt
zeigen wir dass der crash bpk damit nach
vaterschaft aber keine clark vom falter
vater und einander königs vom richtig
gemacht werden
das sind dass alisa leder
das sind prozesse und abläufe und jahren
sieht er hat schon offizin viel
potenzial ich will die menschen
schneller durchaus aber nur
privatwirtschaft üben sagen dass bernard
um auch ist eine freiwillig das gute
noten zu entdecken servus ich halte das
ist aber auch das ist noch interessant
eigentlich ganz ehrlich sei trage
schweizer platz acht
aber dann passiert etwas das diese
aussage relativiert etwas mit dem der
sozial vorstand nicht gerechnet hätte
ein arabischer flüchtling zeigt auf
what's up plötzlich dieses profil bild
[Musik]
es ist jemand der musikbegeisterte aus
syrien
denn ich gern zur schule geht und sich
zu wenig um eine lehrstelle bemüht das
haben wir natürlich sofort ist sie meint
dass die beschäftigung so dass konsole
der arbeit muss sterben
die hand das eigentlich als ein
terrorist in neftenbach bloß das nicht
so viel alarmiert die kantonspolizei
ich treffe diamant in der reformierten
kirche wo er für einen der nächsten
gottesdienste gibt
aber warum denn ein männchen mit einem
blutigen messer also das ist ja schon
noch extrem viel spaß hast du nicht
bestanden dass die leute von der
gemeinde sich sorgen gemacht haben wegen
terrorismus aber nicht nach das so will
ich habe wirklich der eindruck sie haben
dass sie schätze dass ihr kulturkreis
irgendwie anders sie als meter sie
schätzen
weißt du dass es leute gibt das winter
tut das ist ja hier ganz in der nähe die
zum islamischen staat zum ers gegangen
sind um zu kämpfen durch natürlichkeit
nachher das beurteilen wie groß ist das
potenzial also muss man es da
glaubhaften oder der langsam auch
wirklich sehr eingehend mit dem gerettet
hast du je gedacht ich könnte kämpfen
gehen gegen außer nein ich mache das
nicht ich bin ich ein mensch bin der
mensch dem musiker ist ich hoffe dass es
gestaltet die hollywood collection wie
vor drei oder vier wochen haben das
mieten kommen die mütter haben es
weiteres mittel mit ich wollte ich nicht
alle drei oder vier wochen daher
und weil die polizei zum schluss kommt
dass keine terrorgefahr besteht geht sie
am ahnt wieder zur schule und gibt sich
jetzt mehr mühe
aber für ihn ist klar er will arbeiten
nur interessiert er sich für keinen
anderen beruf als musiker sein
notenschnitt liegt bei 2,5 und bis
schulende bleiben nur noch sechs wochen
den syrer beunruhigt das allerdings weit
weniger als den schweizer und der setzt
nun doch wieder ein treffen an
[Musik]
gemeinde und kanton haben sie ermahnt
das zehnte schuljahr bezahlt und sie
würden auch für ein elftes aufkommen
diamant aber will davon nichts wissen
von der gemeinde schon viel
oder ich finde vielleicht schon so viel
wir haben darüber gesprochen kurz aber
es ist viel was sie machen und ich denke
irgendwo müssen sie ja auch ihren
beitrag bringen
ich glaube dass sie das schaffen können
aber es müssen motiviert sein das ist
für mich eigentlich dass das wichtige
wenn sie einfach hängen oder damit ist
das nicht das können sie auch samstags
unter uns nicht und ich möchte dass das
richtig verstehe ist dass sehe was wir
jetzt machen es die letzte chance und
wenn du die nicht passt dann hören wir
auf weitere unterstützung
sie fordern bessere noten und mehr
einsatz bei der lehrstellensuche der
lehrer sagt viele flüchtlinge hätten
mühe verantwortung zu übernehmen
zum schluss kommen sie wieder zurück auf
das whatsup bild das jahr war es für
mich einfach nicht
gewalttaten wie komme ich ohne jede
sekunde betrug führt oder sagen mobile
natürlich das ist bedrohlich werden abo
zugesagt haben ist doch mal ein nehmen
zu den rückkäufen zu also ich mit haupt
nicht also gefährlich ist dass ich zu
kaufen
basiskurs deutsch für anfänger ohne
vorkenntnisse zimmer karsai zwei jahre
nach ihrer ankunft in der schweiz
[Musik]
nicht ganz
annäherung an die sitten des landes
fortschritte und rückschläge das mache
diesen da das gold zu behaupten so
innerhalb posten und dem dritten platz
pächter und ihr seid in einem
asylverfahren und nicht im hotel leisten
bauch hinten serien und hätte ich gut
und siehe da so viel anfangen
ich habe zuerst an boden gut der
asylchef hat eine zwölfmonatige vorliebe
für sie jemand gefunden bin oder nicht
immer alles so schön ist sich voll
überzeugt
und manchmal zahlt sich auch das warten
aus
fast anderthalb jahre saß senders freund
in haft wegen verstoß gegen das
einreiseverbot dies weil die schweiz ein
asylgesuch anders als jenes von sam
behandelt hatte
ob die familie zusammenbleiben kann ist
aber eine andere frage
fielmanns wiedererwägungsgesuch für asyl
in der schweiz ist hängig
[Musik]
die flüchtlinge und wir zeit die zwei
welten zusammenzubringen findet der
sozial vorstand
[Musik]
die 1
das ist ja ein halbes jahr lang haben
wir in neftenbach gedreht die bilanz
zimmer casa profi hofft dass sie in rund
drei jahren einen job findet auf dem
geburtsschein für janetzky unterdessen
14 monate alt ist wartet sie übrigens
immer noch
lamy und ihrer familie auch nach neun
monaten ist unklar ob sie in der schweiz
bleiben können
die mutter aber scheint sich langsam
einzuleben sie andré hahn erlaubt in ein
gemischtes fußball lager zu gehen so
mancher froh dass er wenigstens eine vor
lehrer machen kann
die chancen dass er es packt schätzt auf
50 50
und wenn kritiker jetzt sagen
hoffnungslose fälle wie das läuft in der
schweiz
und ich denke das ist die haupt wie das
läuft schwitzt muss man einfach ein
großer sieg
zum beispiel neftenbach alle gemeinden
haben dasselbe problem kennen die
flüchtlinge in den nächsten jahren nicht
integriert werden
kommt sie das teuer zu stehen darum
investiert neftenbach von anfang an lenz
denken sie einmal aussehen staat dazu
bekommen die nackte stadt das ist jede
hoffnung aber es dankte frau nicht
alternativ
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzklopfen ich weiß es nicht ich das
gar nicht sagt er mir nachfolgen
[Musik]